うん
ダイエット企画の制限をしてから1週間が経ちました
俺は多分今までの人生で
4番目ぐらいに辛い1週間でした言ったからには本気でやってみたんですけどこの1
週間僕が食べたものをご覧下さい
動画どう撮った日の夜でございます今日の夜ご飯は
えっサラダチキン爽やかなハーブの香り距離はあまり食べない方がいいんで
なんかさらづどうか食べるならお昼とか
そのほうがいいかなと思って夜はこれだけにしております
人 new more 夜食恒也色です
カロリーゼロのゼリーとこれがね糖質が0.5%ほぼないです
野菜スティックでございますはい2階の朝です2日目の朝はさ雑資金のハーブ
沢山の5キロからねどのような炭酸水です炭酸が結局に腹が膨らむんでこれ実験しお
任せていけるかがポイントになると思いますいただきますつかめのお昼ご飯です忙しく
てちょっとお昼が遅くなって夕方なんですけども
まず普通にて腹減った普通にカットフルーツのリンゴでこれかなと55kcal しか
ない物ってこんな区
t のかって思うがちょっと食べちゃいますね一度振るカレーサラダンっていうやつ
です
235kcal しかなくて糖質がニーズ2.4g まあこれくらいはありだと思い
ますいただきますはい夜ご飯ですねお腹すくつは
と草野ジャスミンっていうとやっぱりゼリーは博士ナイス糖質ゼロカロリーゼリーただ
月のハーブでございますし
130kcal ぐらいに抑えているのでなかなかいいのじゃないでしょこれ
いただきますございますあぁ sadie 今日の朝食はこちら
ブランパンにこうですね糖質だと2.2g でございますカロリーが70kcal しか
ない
でもしっかり食わないといえば体によくないんでブランパンぐらいからピンじゃないか
なと思ってますいただきます
ヒールです
ですね
頭が1個8008なんで時刻17
ちょっと多いんですけどこれから動くんでお昼はちょっと
ごめんされます夜ご飯です夜ご飯はオクラと波こと病はのネバネバサラダと字チキンで
喪失0
ゼロカロリーぜひ57kcal と103で19サビなんでまぁ夜ご飯だいたい
店キロカロリー切っているくらいですアサディ
改装とじゃこのサラダがとして一定3g の34kcal ブランパン
カロリーが140キロパロディ開きますはいお昼ご飯で割きすぎで冊のシーザーサラダ
芸術9キロカロリー7です野菜スティック140撮影結構あるな148kcal
たとローターのサラダチキンどれシームちょっと少なめで入れますとコンリー多いんで
夜ご飯ですブラッパーンオクラとなめこと山芋のネバネバサラダポテトとハムのサラダ
1週間限定なんですと引き締めていきたいと今回はこの3つよる fudge
はております
もう2がんばれ
a 今日の朝ごはんはこちら blancpain 玉ねぎサラダですねちょっとだけ
ドレッシングをかけて食べさせてくださいはいいただきますお昼 this 野菜して
曲部の野菜スティックで
後ロースハム糖質にず5%カットで
62kcal 糖質が少ない1.6g とかに来てください
た体つきのハーブです
対局で夜ご飯は
ブランパン2個でしましますちょっと今日は疲れてるんで早く寝る作戦ですはい
おはようございます今日の朝ご飯です
茨サポート
のみはいお昼ご飯ですお昼ご飯は
オクラとなめこと山芋のネバネバサラダとブランパン2個でと小花サポートの
グレープフルーツ味でございます
もうちょいて頑張ります今日の夜ご飯ですね
ちょっとコンビニで済ませようと思ったんですけども今日かあちゃんが家に来てまして
ご飯作ってくれましたほぼもやしですねほぼ安いだけど豆腐トニックとかが入ってるん
ですけども高まりとローカロリーで作ってくれたみたいなのでせっかく造っ
てくれたんだよ食べると思いますお母さんありがとうございますはい朝ごはんです回送
ミックスサラダと
のチキン
のおじそうですもう中学で使われます
最強が起きるで今日のお昼は7のサラダチキン
100初恵キロカロリー ae
7で再スティックですね
味噌をなるべく使わず食べていきますこの辺にあったサラダとポジション結構少なめに
つければ
おはようございます a 最終日でございますブランパン2個
振っサラダ speed pop で束ねにたラードにノンオイルドレッシングは王子
そでございますちょっともう結構メートルが崩壊寸前なんで
持ってきていただけます
最強のお昼ご飯ですそれが
最後のご飯になります最後はコバラサポートで終わります
いるこれでっ
終わりなのででこのまま夜に測定しますので結果はまあ夜の休息で
デー
にしてみようと思いますでまぁ
どうだ
マジで
タイツ悪いな hydrogen 見てもらった通りなんですけどもう管理低いのは
分かったと思うんですけども痩せるためにはカロリーだけじゃなくてこの説を抑えるの
も痩せる一つの条件なんですちょっと分厚いやつで撮っていいんですけども糖質の
なるべくを抑えるほうが体にいいんですよするという意味ではなぜカロリーをもちろん
低いんですけども糖質が低いの基本的にたくさん食べましたんで
あんまりで食べゼリーとかコバラサポートとかもあんまり僕は良くないなと思っていた
んですけどもう当分も大事なのでも必要最低限とって今に至ります
見た感じどうですか4組まで結構シュッとしたと思うんですけど
を実際に何キロ減ったが見てから諸原はもう
ないまあまあみんな落ち着け落ち着け大事なのは結果だ
全ては結果には多分元の体重が73点にキロだったんでそこから何か言ったのか
いきます
[音楽]
うんっでもやっぱ者5個はこうこう持ってこう
jan
入っ悪鬼レター
入っていますね
はいはいこちらです結果
はい66.5キログラム
バッハ体調悪いバインド酒席で体調悪いんですけど
どうだこれはこの1週間いろいろな仕事も同じずつで動画を取り付け
それでは食べ物を我慢し運動をほどほどにしてずっ金曜ほぼ毎日してかここまできたよ
ねじゃあ実際でホッとするくらいけど義務を断っても終わりかけでもうちょい振って車
た生まれるぐらいの共生なんですよ
というわけで一緒になってる
う16.5 k でしょなんか減ったんだざっくりエクと
8キロぐらい減ってますねやんば俺
どんだけいやすごいだけど票的なデフレだと思いますてかあの1週間僕やってることっ
て結構危ないと思うんですよ
日まで僕ちょっと自分を追い込む曲がありましたあのどうやってここまで来たことで
説明しましょう今日的に水面包茎は炭酸水かお茶しか飲みませんで食べた炎は先ほど
動画で説明したもののみです
ブランパンがそのすごい効いてたあのカロリーだけじゃなくてば糖質を制限することっ
てすごく大事だと思ってちょっと1週間
マジで意識ぶっ飛びそうだったしなんかて痺れてきたしなんかメンターがちょっと物故
れそうになってサウナが週3回ぐらい行って運動ガッツリいる自覚がないんで1日に1
時間ぐらいパスキャラ腹筋やら何かしらの
運動はしてましたうまいこと言う33と止め33どう組み合わせてやってたんであても
やっぱり一番ていくだったの食事制限だったと思います
正直腹減りすぎて死にそうでした毎日な痩せたいと思ってる奴らー
阿波得てんじゃねーよああいやでもホント真似はしないでねただ僕やってるのはまずで
危険なルールだと思うんでがまずやしないで欲しいんですけど
まあほんとね
結構つらかったねまあそれだけ来るとここまでこれるということが実証できたのでは
ないでしょうか
結構最強レベルに辛いダイエットだったと思うんですけど肌との翼をほか
体感しました元無理です1週間以上メディこれ以上続けるために本ブリアンザ
というわけで今日から普通の仕方に戻ろうと思います
ただやっぱりバンドが強いのでいきなり長さとめちゃくちゃ撮ったり油っぽいを受け
たりするとまた来ないバンド太るんでちょっと気をつけていこうと思いますじゃあ
[音楽]
car
me
あっはぁ